♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THE STATE OF THE UNION
ADDRESS IS STILL SCHEDULED
TO TAKE PLACE NEXT WEEK BUT
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHERE IT WILL
BE DELIVERED.
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
NANCY PELOSI HAS SAID THE
PRESIDENT IS NOT WELCOME IN
THE HOUSE.
THE LATEST ON THAT JUST
AHEAD.
FIRST, THERE WAS A BRIEF
MOMENT, A SMALL WINDOW AT
THE BEGINNING OF THIS WEEK
WHEN IT SEEMED POSSIBLE THAT
OUR MEDIA ESTABLISHMENT
MIGHT LOOK INWARD AND LEARN
SOMETHING USEFUL ABOUT
ITSELF HUMILIATION WAS THE
BEST TEACHER AND DEFINITELY
HUMILIATED IN THE SPACE OF A
FEW DAYS TWO SEPARATE HIGH
PROFILE NEWS STORIES TURNED
OUT TO BE UTTERLY
FRAUDULENT.
FIRST, BUZZFEED ANNOUNCED
THAT FORMER TRUMP LAWYER
MICHAEL COHEN HAD BEEN
COACHED TO COMMIT PERJURY BY
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
THE CABLE NEWS CAUCUS
IMMEDIATELY ERUPTED IN GLEE
FINALLY WE GOT HIM UNTIL
ROBERT MUELLER'S OFFICE
WEIGHED IN TO POINT OUT THAT
THE STORY THRILLING AS IT
SOUNDED WASN'T STRICTLY
SPEAKING TRUE.
SO THAT WAS EMBARRASSING.
AND THEN, JUST 24 HOURS
LATER, OUR ENTIRE RULING
CLASS, UNITED AS ONE, TO
CRUSH A GROUP OF CATHOLIC
SCHOOL BOYS FROM KENTUCKY
WHO HAD APPARENTLY BEHAVED
DISRESPECTFULLY TOWARD AN
AMERICAN INDIAN MAN HERE IN
WASHINGTON.
A SHORT VIDEO CLIP ON SOCIAL
MEDIA APPEARED TO TELL THAT
STORY.
THE ONLY PROBLEM WAS THERE
WERE OTHER, MUCH LONGER
VIDEOS OF THE VERY SAME
EVENT AND THEY REVEALED A
VERY DIFFERENT TRUTH.
THE STUDENTS FROM COVINGTON
CATHOLIC DID NOT HARASS
ANYONE.
IN FACT, THEY WERE THE ONES
BEING HARASSED, OWCH.
VARIOUS MEDIA LUMINAIRES
SWIFTLY DELETED THEIR
SCOLDING TWEETS.
SOME EVEN APOLOGIZED FOR
THEM FOR GETTING IT WRONG.
SELF-AWARENESS MADE A RARE
APPEARANCE IN THE NATIONAL
PRESS CORPS.
BUT THE MOMENT PASSED
QUICKLY.
IT IS ALWAYS PAINFUL TO
CONCEDE YOUR MISTAKES
ESPECIALLY THE MISTAKES YOU
MAKE BECAUSE HAVE YOU
ALLOWED MINDLESS STEREO
TYPES RATHER THAN FACTS TO
SHAPE YOUR UNDERSTANDING OF
THE WORLD.
NOBODY WANTS TO ADMIT THAT.
IT'S MUCH EASIER TO BLAME
OTHERS AND SO THE MEDIA DID
JUST THAT YESTERDAY, "THE
WASHINGTON POST" RAN A STORY
THAT SUMMED UP THE NEW
CONSENSUS ON THE COVINGTON
STUDENTS.
HERE IT IS.
QUOTE:  A VIRAL STORY
SPREAD, THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
RUSHED TO KEEP UP THE TRUMP
INTERNET POUNCED.
GOT IT?
THE REAL VILLAINS HERE ARE
NOT THE JOURNALISTS WHO
PUSHED FOR INNOCENT KIDS TO
BE EXPELLED FROM SCHOOL AND
PUNCHED IN THE FACE.
THE REAL BAD GUYS ARE THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE OFFENDED BY
THE FAKE STORY.
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO,
QUOTE.
POUNCED.
THAT'S WHAT BAD PEOPLE DO IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST"
HEADLINES.
THEY POUNCE.
SO, HAVING ABSOLVED
THEMSELVES OF ANY WRONGDOING
AND RECAST THEMSELVES AS THE
REAL VICTIMS HERE, THE MEDIA
WENT BACK ON THE OFFENSIVE
AGAINST THE COVINGTON
STUDENTS.
ONE OF THOSE STUDENTS, A BOY
CALLED NICK SANDMANN MADE
THE MISTAKE OF GOING ON NBC
THIS MORNING AND HERE IS
WHAT HAPPENED NEXT.
>> DO YOU FEEL FROM THIS
EXPERIENCE THAT YOU OWE
ANYBODY AN APOLOGY?
DO YOU SEE YOUR OWN FAULTS?
HAVE YOU LOOKED AT THAT
VIDEO AND THOUGHT ABOUT HOW
IT FELT FROM THE OTHER'S
PERSPECTIVE?
IN OTHER WORDS, THERE WERE A
LOT OF YOU, A HANDFUL OF THE
OTHERS?
DO YOU THINK THEY MIGHT HAVE
FELT THREATENED BY A BUNCH
OF YOUNG MEN KIND OF BEATING
THEIR CHESTS?
DO YOU THINK IF YOU WEREN'T
WEARING THAT HAT THIS MIGHT
NOT HAVE HAPPENED OR IT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN DIFFERENT?
SOMETHING AGGRESSIVE ABOUT
STANDING THERE, STANDING
YOUR GROUND.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
THERE IS SOMETHING
AGGRESSIVE ABOUT STANDING
THERE.
FAILING TO MOVE IS A HOSTILE
ACT.
WE CAN'T HAVE PEOPLE
STANDING STILL IN PUBLIC
PLACES.
GET A MOVE ON, SON.
THAT'S WHAT NBC IS TELL US.
JUST KIDDING.
NBC IS ACTUALLY FINE WITH
PEOPLE STANDING AROUND.
MOST PEOPLE ANYWAY.
GO AHEAD AND MAKE THE CASE
FOR LOITERING LAWS AND SEE
WHAT HAPPENS.
NBC WILL ATTACK YOU AS A
FASHIONIST BEFORE YOU FINISH
THE SENTENCE.
NBC DOESN'T THINK THAT
PEOPLE LIKE NICK SANDMANN
SHOULD STAND IN PLACE IS
QUOTE, AGGRESSIVE.
GEORGEORWELL IMAGINED A
WORLD LIKE THIS 70 YEARS AGO
IN 1984 FOR THE DISPAFERRED,
ORWELL WROTE THE SMALLEST
THING COULD GIVE YOU A WAY A
NERVOUS TICK, UNCONSCIOUS
HABIT OF MUTTERING TO
YOURSELF.
TO SAY WEAR AN IMPROPER
EXPRESSION ON YOUR FACE WAS
ITSELF A PUNISHABLE OFFENSE.
THERE WAS EVEN A WORD FOR IT
FACE CRIME.
NICK SANDMANN COMMITTED FACE
CRIME ON FRIDAY.
JUST SOMETHING ABOUT HIS
FACE.
SOMETHING AGGRESSIVE AND
SNEERING.
FOR THAT CRIME SOME OF OUR
SUPERIORS DON'T BELIEVE THAT
NICK SAMMAN OUGHT TO BE
ALLOWED TO SPEAK IN PUBLIC.
LET MSNBC EXPLAINED.
>> THERE WAS THIS ATTEMPT TO
GIVE A FULLER ACCOUNT OF THE
YOUNG MAN.
AND I THINK A LOT OF FOLKS
WERE ASKING THE QUESTION
WHEN -- WHY DO WE ALWAYS DO
THIS IN THESE SORTS OF CASES
WHEN WHITE BOYS ARE
INVOLVED?
WE GIVE PRIVILEGE TO THESE
WHITE KIDS.
HE CAN SIT DOWN WITH SAVANNA
GUTHRIE AND REDEEM HIMSELF
BUT THEN THERE ARE ALL OF
THESE OTHER FOLKS WHO WE
JUST PRESUME, YOU KNOW, WHO
AREN'T SO INNOCENT.
>> Tucker: PRIVILEGE.
THAT'S THE REAL PROBLEM
HERE.
NICK SANDMANN HAS TOO MUCH
PRIVILEGE.
SO SAYS THE TENURED
PRINCETON PROFESSOR WITH THE
CABLE CONTRACT.
THAT PROFESSOR BY THE WAY
WORKS NINE MONTHS A YEAR FOR
A GUARANTEED SALARY THAT
PUTS HIM IN THE TOP 2% OF
ALL WAGE EARNERS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
HIS DAY JOB HAS SO FEW
DEMANDS THAT HE CAN SPEND
MOST OF HIS TIME SITTING
AROUND A TV STUDIO WEARING
MAKEUP AND STILL THE VICTIM
OF NICK SANDMANN'S
PRIVILEGE.
THE IVY LEAGUE PROFESSOR HAS
FAR LESS PRIVILEGE THAN NICK
SANDMANN WHO IS A CATHOLIC
SCHOOL STUDENT FROM ONE OF
THE COUNTRY'S POORIST
STATES.
WAY LESS PRIVILEGED DOESN'T
EVEN COMPARE THAT'S THE CASE
THEY ARE MAKING.
LET'S BE HONEST.
THIS ENTIRE CONVERSATION
ISN'T REALLY RELATED TO WHAT
HAPPENED OUTSIDE THE LINCOLN
MEMORIAL LAST FRIDAY.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE ANGRIEST
AT NICK SANDMANN AND HIS
CLASSMATES DON'T ACTUALLY
CARE WHAT HAPPENED THERE
THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW.
THEY HAVEN'T WATCHED THE
VIDEO.
THEY DON'T PLAN.
TO SAY THIS NOT AN ARGUMENT
ABOUT FACTS AND EVIDENCE AND
TRUTH.
IT'S AN ARGUMENT ABOUT
IDENTITY.
THE KENTUCKY STUDENTS ARE
BEING ATTACKED FOR WHO THEY
ARE NOT FOR WHAT THEY DID OR
DIDN'T DO.
THE SOONER THE REST OF US
UNDERSTAND THAT THE SOONER
WE WILL UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
AT STAKE HERE.
EVERYTHING IS AT STAKE HERE.
MOST SPECIFICALLY OUR
ABILITY COLLECTIVELY TO LIVE
AT PEACE IN A MULTIETHNIC
SOCIETY.
THERE IS NO LONGER AN
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY GROUP
IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT A DIVERSE COUNTRY AS WE
ARE OFTEN TOLD.
THERE IS NOTHING WRONG WITH
THAT.
BUT IT TAKES THOUGHTFUL
LEADERS TO PULL IT OFF.
THE PRESUMPTION OF EQUALITY
IS A TRUE REQUISITE FOR A
DIVERSE COUNTRY.
ONCE PEOPLE START BELIEVING
THAT SOME GROUPS ARE
INHERENTLY INFERIOR TO OTHER
GROUPS, THEY HAVE MORE
PRIVILEGE.
THEY SHOULDN'T BE ALLOWED TO
STAND IN PUBLIC.
THERE IS SOMETHING ABOUT
THEIR FACES WE DON'T LIKE.
WHEN PEOPLE START THINKING
THAT, THE WHOLE PROJECT
FALLS APART.
PEOPLE START HATING EACH
OTHER.
AND NOT HATING EACH OTHER
FOR THEIR OPINIONS, WE COULD
FIX THAT.
PEOPLE'S VIEWS EVOLVE OVER
TIME.
POLITICAL DIVISIONS CAN HEAL
AND OFTEN DO.
BUT, FIGHTS OVER IDENTITY DO
NOT.
THEY ARE DIFFERENT.
IDENTITY DOES NOT CHANGE.
IT CANNOT BE MODERATED OR
CONTROLLED.
IT'S INHERENT.
WE'RE BORN THAT WAY.
WHEN WE GO TO WAR OVER WHO
WE ARE, IT IS A PERMANENT
BATTLE.
IT IS A DISASTER THAT LASTS
FOR GENERATIONS.
IDENTITY POLITICS WILL
DESTROY THIS COUNTRY FASTER